[Applause]
drew loves elmo and drew is so excited
to announce elmo is our next guest hello
[Applause]
elmo hi i'm so happy to see you i'm so
excited that you're here joining us on
our daytime show now
let me ask you yeah what's it like
having a late night not so late night
show yeah well you know almost bedtime
is 7 30.
so it's like it's not that late but it's
not early no it's fun we have a really
good time you know elmo is really having
a great time doing a show with all of
his friends you know burt and ernie are
the director yeah and and rosita's the
stage manager oh and you know what we
have a helper chicken named felix he
helps around the studio do you have a
helper chicken i actually have six
chickens elmo
they're my daughters
and they we all adopted them when they
were tiny baby chicks they would fit in
the palm of our hands and we raised them
since they were babies
they're chickens yeah
emma's gonna have to think about that
one
well i hope so we can meet them oh i
would love to introduce you to our
chickens um we have uh percy pepper
blanche sparkles ferdinand
and
branch
well that's great almost can't wait to
meet them you know what's interesting uh
about today elmo
guess who's gonna get to be on your not
so late show this evening well
elmo's gonna give a little bit of a
spoiler alert but miss drew
did the naturalistic it's true
oh i'm so honored i can't think of a
show that exists on the planet let alone
television that i wouldn't be more
excited to be on than your show elmo
thank you for having me yeah almost
blushing you can't tell because that was
red but elmo let's bless you
well i want to ask you what is your
favorite part about having your own show
well you know elmo gets to meet a lot of
new friends you know the contestants
come in and they're kids and they come
in with their mommies or daddies or
grandparents or caretakers and we we get
to play and dance and have a great time
oh that is just so wonderful now let me
ask you a question because i have a lot
of homework every night for the show and
guests do you have a lot of homework
well emma didn't know that elmo was
supposed to research the guests until it
was like a little too late
but you know that's what google's for
everyone just did a quick google search
well it's funny because you're a really
good teacher um oh yeah oh yeah how
about those teachers are very important
yeah i think you've pretty much taught
us a lot about what we know
um oh sure i can think of so many
lessons i've learned from you
whether it's about how to take care of a
fish to how important it is to be kind
to each other you know it's interesting
because elmo does have a fish named
dorothy but elmo also just got a brand
new puppy
yeah and yeah her name is tango and
almost learning a lot about how to take
care of a dog and it's you know it's
really hard taking care of a dog drew um
they run around they you know they they
go to the bathroom
someone didn't even think about that
elmo just said i'm almost a dog and then
who knew
we're having a great time no one loves
this doggy one time my dog uh went to
the bathroom inside my shoe
and that was that was a real surprise
that's why elmo doesn't wear shoes
[Laughter]
well since the leaves are turning yeah
it's beautiful in here oh look at all
the leaves thank you
um it's becoming fall which is such a
beautiful season and i wanted to see if
you would play a little game with us
okay okay it's called fall faves
[Music]
[Applause]
okay all is two classic fall things and
we'll choose which is our fall favorite
and our audience gets to play along too
so you guys have the green side be your
first choice and the red side be your
second choice elmer are you ready
okay let's see here we go
do you like apple cinnamon or pumpkin
spice
pumpkin spice
let's see apple cinnamon is green
pumpkin spice is red
oh okay 50 50. i was just going to say
even
who is steven why do we say that yeah
stephen can we get that answer please
stephen yeah
talk about a google search elmo i'm
going to do that tonight
okay
you know what's funny how about this do
you know why they say it's raining cats
and dogs yeah why do they say that
because back in the old days when houses
were made from adobe and mud the cats
and dogs would go up in the rafters and
when it would rain it would get so muddy
they would slip down so they'd fall from
the ceiling
that's crazy isn't it crazy
you learn something new every day that's
exactly right yeah okay spooky or cozy
uh look at that well because it's
because it's fall elmo's gonna say
spooky
all right green for spooky red for cozy
elmo
i think that's another looks like effect
even still them yeah
that's right yeah okay sweaters or
jackets oh sweaters or jackets see
that's why it's difficult for elmo
because elmo's already very warm with
the fur
but but just just for the sake of the
game elmo's going to say sweaters
you kind of do kind of a sweater yeah
exactly
it's true well then just for that i'm
going to say sweaters as well what about
you guys sweaters or jackets
it's pretty close pretty close yeah it's
a little even steven still maybe a
little more sweaters yeah um all right
last one trick
for green red
for
treat i almost got to say treat
and guess what look
in it
in honor of you it's all red everybody
likes a treat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you